hey guys how's it going so we've got a
little announcement to make for you oh
my god I've made a video to it I meet
one today I know how hey guys let's go
now we've got an announcement for you so
every year for the past couple of years
we've been going to comic-con and we've
had exclusive hoodies at the system
happy booth this is true will ya
but it's true mr. oh it's true so
mission your I'm pretty excited because
we made these really sweet t-shirts
their best friend t-shirts should well
actually you can put thinking again yeah
like here I love it it's coffee and
doughnuts basically like ours actually
oh yeah any of you guys happened to be
going to comic-con or you're in San
Diego and you can sneak in a comic-con
come and see us this Thursday what's the
details I need the I need the beat
Thursday January not in January
well there's day July 9th noon to 2
o'clock
booth 5 0 3 7 the so so happy booths we
should try the ice tea and find some
footage from last year you guys will see
it it's freaking just bright and
beautiful and it looks like a festive do
parade of happiness really yeah
and we'll be there so you see us you're
at the right place
what else should we talk about because
that's really the key part of this video
that I want to talk about but I feel
like just talk about something else
tournaments let's talk about something
that I bought and Jenna told me I would
never use oh come on you six months ago
and you yes use it you only just now
found it so I was running illnesses with
my walls working another beast a run
don't mess with my ed sheeran mystic
version six
helmet not on here so this is the Apple
Store and I used to actually play guitar
and Jenna can tell you all about it
it should play like 4:00 in the morning
I'm like why your room is right next to
me and I'm sleeping and you're awful
next time I go home I should bring my
guitar back it's like this hot pink
fender it's a hot pink fender where's
the new crap you're gonna do you're
gonna get checkout so I've been doing
this vine series oh no it's uh so Jenna
is like my fake backup singer but she
doesn't know how to be a backup so
you're so let's do one should we do it
oh so your name so first of all I'm not
bit like I don't know any backup singer
hope you've listened to this oh wait
I've been running driving running
through the six with my wolves I mean
like running through six what's the six
like I think that's like a area code
like part of an area code I've been run
and do my mine through the six winter
with my own personal okay
I'm Dexter I was a whole my god you are
Dexter I'm running through the six the
six with my clothes you know how that go
I don't think we're done I never done
say I'll see you guys Thursday I can't
wait to see you I'm so excited for you
see the t-shirts make sure you wear your
finest so so happy or just wear some
clothes and we'll put the information in
the description because what not show
you're sure that doesn't mean something
bad running through the six it does it
all right guys we're done now
what does running through the six means
it does not mean anything by that make
sure
urban as in a whoa a tornado street
slang for dope going through your
neighborhood carrying your problems and
sorrows yet still survived I was running
through looking at it - sighs let me
define something else for you it's
actually old English woes is now
commonly known as the ho
stemming from for the 1960s it
could mean anything you wanted to me I
would like to take it as I'm hanging out
in my neighborhood with my friends they
hangin on my neighborhood with my
friends yeah okay bye guys see you later
you